I'm Brian Ross joined tonight as always
by my colleague Rhonda Schwartz and
Rhonda story as you know that we thought
what we had was a bombshell interview
with former Playboy Playmate Karen
McDougall who is going to lay out all
the details of what she said was a
steamy 10-month affair with Donald Trump
that's right Brian and then suddenly she
canceled the interview it was only later
we learned that the National Enquirer
and a deal worked out by then president
Trump's personal attorney had promised
her a hundred and fifty thousand dollars
in to promote her career as a fitness
model if she didn't talk about the
affair it's a practice that's become
known as catch and kill and of course
what we wanted to do was catch and
broadcast and now four years later after
we came up with some new information
Kerry McDougall has finally agreed to
answer our questions on the record along
with her lawyer Carol Heller telling us
she now has asked for God's forgiveness
or her sins you know God forgives
repented for what I've done what I did
back then with McDonald I've apologized
publicly and most importantly I've been
forgiven by juice so I'm happy I'm at
peace I love where I'm at today and
honestly I love who I am today
and you feel like you had to repent for
what happened with Donald Trump
absolutely I had to I I knew it was
wrong it was a thinning God eyes in
God's eyes
um yeah I repented and you know I'm not
going to keep apologizing for it because
I've already apologized I've already
repented and you know I'm I'm forgiven
and In My Father's Eyes so the world can
look at me how they look at me and
that's okay I understand
um but I've moved on and I'm happy do
you imagine Donald Trump has in any way
repented
oh
um I can't say what what he has and
hasn't done with his wife and his family
but
um I doubt it when her story did come
out it was big news they met she says in
June 2006 at this party at the Playboy
Mansion during the filming of The
Apprentice wow throughout the night it
was kind of obvious that there was an
attraction from his part to me only
later with the story of the 150 000
payment come out and as you recall prior
to the signing the deal you were talking
with me what Rhonda Schwartz about doing
an interview when we worked at ABC news
then and then that got canceled the deal
was canceled because we had signed the
deal with AMI in order for me to work
and never talk about it again I never
talk about the relationship and were we
kind of
so we were sort of leveraged for you in
a way
I didn't know that
at the term was more than willing to
talk to you and did in great detail
knowing with no expectations of having
any kind of compensation and I think
people should be aware of that that you
were not ever giving a promise to pay
anything it was going to be completely
gratis
the White House has denied that Trump
had a sexual relationship with Karen
McDougall but she says she kept a
calendar or diary of the 10 months he
was with Trump making note of each time
they had sex including one episode she
says at Trump's New York City Apartment
when his wife Melania was out of town
and were you in love with him
I was back then am I now which everyone
has accused me of based on the less and
the one and only interview I've done no
I'm not in love with him today was I
back then for my own personal reasons
yes I thought that I was and what do you
make of him today
no comments
um
you know I
um you know Brian that was 14 years ago
that I knew Donald
AKA president Trump as we know him today
um I don't think that he's the same
person that I knew I think back then he
seemed much sweeter nicer more concerned
about people's feelings
um you know the man I personally knew
was not this man that I see on TV now do
I disagree and or agree with his
policies there are some I like and some
I disprove of greatly and she says she
litter heard from people at the National
Enquirer that Trump when he was
president wanted to know if she was
still interested in him I was asked it's
all hearsay of course I was asked if
um I still cared or loved Donald and I
said why do you ask that and he said
well Donald was asking somebody does she
still love me
I just laughed it off I don't know yeah
no no I don't love him but no I just
laughed off the situation so Karen
looking back on uh looking back on this
four-year Saga do you wish perhaps you
had done the interview with us and
called it done
I do actually
um it was a whole big ordeal I just wish
I would have come clean in the beginning
let it out and kind of relax after that
because it was it was a um kind of a
nightmare for a while and in every sense
of the word and from A to Z it was a
flat out nightmare Brian it was very
scary I actually went into hiding for a
while
um even though it's hiding I had strange
people follow me around uh knocking at
my door uh different times of the day
scared to death following me home from
events Church whatever it was pretty
scary and it's nothing I really want to
do again if you have to tell the truth
you must tell the truth so at the same
time it's kind of a known situation you
tell the truth no good deed goes
unpenished but yet I don't know Brian
it's just a weird situation I got myself
into and it was just the two of us as
you know except we weren't really backed
by anyone it was just the two of us
alone and I think we did pretty well
together Karen are you supporting a
candidate in particular this year in the
presidential election
the candidate that I feel best unifies
us as a country
and I'll leave it at that all right well
uh Carol Heller and Karen McDougall
thank you so much for being with us here
tonight
thank you thank you